oh wow do you say the f word yeah I say  words yeah like what [ __ ] what [ __ ] damn  hell oh wow that's pretty edgy I bet you  kill people too oh you bet I do but only  generic bad guys who if you didn't kill  them would likely harm the supporting  characters so it's  it's basically self-defense right [ __ ]  you what was that [ __ ] you oh somebody  called the cop I don't care about good  or evil I'm so bad someone better remind  me of my tragic backstory someone better  give me a character Arc  oh hey that bad thing you did in the  past doesn't Define you you're you you  can change you're a good guy I believe  I'm good now I'm  God nice great do you still say [ __ ]  only in the deleted scenes yes